hey I'm Kazama Nagy I'm going to make my
favorite sandwich it is a turkey pepper
jack cheese
Chipotle melts we'll start off with this
is very bougie actually you don't need
to go by chipotle mayo a life hack is
you can take mayonnaise and put sriracha
in go to sandwich and I was a kid was
the peanut butter and jelly my secret
was I would toast it I think cool
sandwiches are just kind of like
depressing and sad basically what I do
is I divide it up into hot region and
cold region so this stuff's going to get
heated so we toast this stuff's going to
remain cold now we're going to do pepper
jack cheese which is great because
there's like American or Swiss but I
feel like pepper jack cheese and cheese
this heavily slept on I'm going to cut
it up into thin slices I want there to
be like a really really nice meat to
cheese to sauce ratio then when like the
confluence happens it is bananas this is
where beautiful things can happen when
you toast this and if you toast it right
like you have a really good relationship
with your toaster oven what you'll get
is you'll get this like really cool nice
like crispy meat and then you'll get
melted cheese I don't know why I'm doing
it this way but I just noticed that they
do it that way it's subway and so I'm
just like alright do it that way or it
takes us over it's a really nice toaster
oh do you want to hear a horror story so
if there's one thing that I'll never
have on a sandwich I'll never have ever
again it's ketchup and I was in the
second grade we used to have lunch at
school and this kid Travis Wilson he had
a bloody nose and we had french fries
for lunch and his nose was just bleeding
and he was eating the french fries with
ketchup he's like can I have your gummy
bears and it's like bleeding so it was
going from his nose and to his mouth as
he was eating fries with ketchup to this
day I can't stand ketchup I can't be a
round ketchup if I have french fries I
eat them with mustard I can do
mayonnaise which is gross it's a gross
condiment we just all accept it let's go
to Arielle cam here if you just zoom in
right now this is I call this the booger
of the tomato I really don't like tomato
but
onions so good it's like not good for
breath but it's like it's got a great
crunch to the luxury you guys this is
the make-or-break condiment that you add
on a sandwich to let you know where's
where are you at financially in your
life no matter where you are like
Chipotle Subway the add avocado question
really is the what tax bracket are you
in in your sandwich life for the longest
time I was not in an avocado position
now we're going to go over here we're
going to look to see Amen man is going
to be incredible you can see that life
is like two cooked over slightly it's
like a baked turkey which is fantastic
and the cheese is like it's almost like
bubbling and gooey like a like a cheese
pizza now we just put our toppings on
all right we got Tomatoes here and the
luxury item of them all all man
we're balling today here we go perfect
as is
look I've just been waiting for the
right moment you know how like you get
to a certain level in like your life or
career where they're like oh the lamest
sandwich after you this is the Minaj
o'clock I'm shooting 0% from that
department but I've had a lot of these
magic one literally zero of the other
kind of here we go
that's really good
okay if I finish this